cool dad why the fancy red suit mr. pool
oh that's because it's christmas day
dopinder and i'm after someone on my
naughty list you're probably thinking
this was a superhero movie but that guy
in the suit just turned that other guy
into a kebab surprise this is a
different kind of superhero story to
tell it right we got to take you back
before I squeezed into red spandex mr.
Wilson you've recently been diagnosed
with terminal cancer we can fight this
what if I told you we can cure you and
give you abilities most men only dream
of I'd say that you sound like an
infomercial but not a good one like Slap
Chop more shake weighty if I never see
you again
know that I love you when I'm finished
it mutates it cells will heal anything
but you still think we're making you a
suit being right we're making you a
super slave come on you gonna leave me
all alone here with Jose Canseco
whatever they did to me made my body
indestructible
but my face no look at me I know look at
it no I don't want it exactly I didn't
ask to be super and I'm no hero but when
you find out your worst enemy is after
your best girl the time has come to be a
superhero cue the music
we can't allow this Deadpool I don't
have time for your x-men bull Colossus
besides nobody's getting hurt that guy
was up there before we got here would I
put a lot of rules damsel in distress
they wanna
wait did I leave the stove on you're way
too much dude for me that's why I
brought them I mean that's why I brought
her oh no finish your tweet go get her
tiger
so pity the dude who pressures her into
prom sex smell